un travail
mercredi
m
le délire
meyer a récupéré
décembre 1922 le premier congrès des
soviets de l'urss confirme le traité
d'union signée par la russie la
biélorussie l'ukraine et la
transcaucasie rejoint peu après par les
républiques d'asie centrale kirghizie et
turkestan elle recouvre la plus grande
partie de l'ancien empire russe
cet accord qui intervient cinq ans après
la chute du régime tsariste donnera le
jour à l'union des républiques
socialistes soviétiques mais il faut
remonter cinq ans plus tôt en russie
abba l'ancien régime une longue série de
manifestations et de grèves culmine à
petrograd à partir du 23 février 1917 et
se transforme en cinq jours
insurrectionnel animé par des soldats et
des ouvriers ont réponse au mot d'ordre
la paix à bas l'autocratie
la troupe est envoyée elle se mutine et
fraternisent avec les manifestants le 27
février les insurgés rejoignent la douma
le parlement dominé par les partis
bourgeois le soviet de petrograd conseil
des ouvriers des soldats reconnaît la
légitimité d'un gouvernement provisoire
nommé par la douma qui obtient
l'abdication du tsar nicolas ii
tandis que l'effroyable boucherie de la
première guerre mondiale se poursuit le
gouvernement provisoire dirigé par
kerenski est incapable d'imposer la
justice sociale la réforme agraire et la
paix alors qu'il tente de restaurer
l'autorité de l'état en pleine
décomposition
chaque ville chaque région de lempire
créer son propre sort hier le facteur
qui ont déclenché le processus
révolutionnaire en russie c'est la
guerre la lassitude des soldats de se
battre des soldats paysans donc qui
avait aussi foncièrement le désir de
régler la question agraire qui était la
grande question qui déstabilisait
l'ordre social le en russie depuis bien
avant évidemment 1914 ce processus qui
aboutit ou révolution de 1917 à
commencer évidemment bien avant avec
l'abolition du servage en 1861 ça c'est
la composante paysanne soldats il y a
aussi une composante ouvrière qui est
beaucoup mieux connue qui est la force
du mouvement révolutionnaire dans les
villes
néanmoins cette classe ouvrière
extrêmement exploités ne représentent
qu'une toute petite fraction de la
population 2 à 3 millions d'ouvriers
de prolétariat industriels à proprement
parler en russie au moment de la
révolution et de la guerre de 14 18
le pain la terre la paix tels sont les
mots d'ordre du parti communiste
bolchévique dirigé par lénine qui rallie
les masses radicaliser
en octobre 17 les bolchéviks sont
devenus majoritaires au deuxième congrès
des soviets ouvriers soldats de russie
le gouvernement provisoire est renversé
lénine était du président du conseil des
commissaires du peuple qui adoptent le
décret sur la paix et celui sur la terre
confisquant la grande propriété sont
aussi instauré séparation de l'église et
de l'état
égalité des droits pour les femmes
contrôle ouvrier des entreprises journée
de huit heures lénine et a eu beaucoup
de mal à imposer au sein même du parti
bolchévik sa théorie de prise du pouvoir
en octobre 17 car beaucoup d'autres au
sein du parti bolchévik attendait une
voix
disons moins révolutionnaire mais
voulait attendre que se réunisse
l'assemblée constituante pour procéder à
cette prise du pouvoir
la question de la prise du pouvoir par
les bolchéviques est une question qui
d'emblée a suscité une très grande
controverse est ce que là les
bolchéviques sont arrivés au pouvoir par
une révolution populaire
un mouvement de fond des masses
ouvrières ou bien est-ce que c'est en
octobre 17 simplement un coup d'état il
faut voir que cette révolution est
d'abord une révolution multiples ce à
quoi on assiste en 1917
c'est à une sorte de libération d'abord
de la parole libération sociale qui va
un petit peu dans tous les sens mais il
ne faut pas oublier non plus que dans ce
grand mouvement d'émancipation les
nationalités de l'empiré russe ont vu
dans les événements de 1917 une
possibilité d'émancipation que ce soit
les baltes les ukrainiens les musulmans
du turkestan les caucasiens
avec un très fort mouvement d'autonomie
en géorgie par exemple en arménie toutes
ces révolutions distingue ont eu pour
effet une dissolution du pouvoir
étatique
malgré toutes les tentatives des divers
gouvernements provisoires de restaurer
une autorité de l'état et profitant en
effet du vide du pouvoir même d'une
véritable dislocation de toute autorité
les bolchéviks ont pris le pouvoir
porter par un vaste mouvement populaire
mais sans lequel cette prise du pouvoir
assez inattendu en effet n'aurait pas pu
avoir lieu
l'armée rouge est constituée sous la
direction de trotski ainsi que la tchéka
police politique dirigée par jean ce qui
met le problème de la guerre n'est pas
réglé elle met en péril la révolution
russe les bolchéviks font des
propositions d'une paix sans élection ni
contribution rejetée par les
belligérants
ils obtiennent un armistice avec les
empires centraux en décembre 17 mai face
à une offensive éclair allemande en
février 18 sont amenés à signer le
traité de paix de brest-litovsk
cependant dans une russie gravement
affaibli par la guerre le pouvoir est
attaqué par des éléments de sa rist qui
dominent des régions entières et
reçoivent l'appui de la france et de
l'angleterre
c'est l'instauration du communisme de
guerre l'état prend le contrôle total de
l'économie et les mesures répressives
sont renforcés provoquant le soulèvement
des paysans hostile aux réquisitions
comme en ukraine
sous la direction de l'anarchiste nestor
makhno l'armée rouge fini par avoir
raison des troubles
ariste en 1920
mais la population est à bout la
production industrielle s'est effondrée
les transports sont désorganisés les
paysans refusent les réquisitions et
réduisent volontairement les récoltes
les marins de cronstadt se révoltent la
pénurie est généralisée et la famine va
faire des centaines de milliers de
victimes
malgré des divergences entre lénine et
joseph staline commissaire aux
nationalités la constitution de l'urss
est votée le 31 janvier 1924
l'union est constitué de onze états ego
fédérer dont la plus grande partie des
pouvoirs est dévolue au gouvernement
central mais si la structure de l'état
soviétique et fédérative le parti
bolchévik lui reste fortement
centralisée ce qui s'est passé au moment
de la guerre civile
c'était que le centre russe c'est à dire
bon le pouvoir central à réprimer très
fortement toutes les velléités
d'indépendance des diverses république
et a joué objectivement le rôle qu'avait
eu l' empire tsariste c'est-à-dire de
rassembler ses diverses nationalités
que ce passe-t-il à partir de 1922
surtout en 22 il y à un grand débat
notamment entre lénine et staline qui
lui
souhaité laisser moins de tonneaux me et
qui souhaitait un contrôle quand même
beaucoup plus grands du centre sur les
diverses régions et républiques
autonomes ou fédérer en europe
la finlande la pologne et les états
baltes recouvrent leur indépendance
les bolchéviks sont restés fidèles aux
principes de la révolution mondiale
c'est dans cet esprit qu'a été créé en
l'internationale communiste sous
l'influencé de staline
son rôle au cours du temps se
restreindra à la défense de l'état
soviétique
suivant la théorie du développement du
socialisme dans un seul pays
pour lénine le passage ou socialisme
demandera du temps
le 10e congrès du parti communiste
bolchévique adoptant mars 1921 une
nouvelle politique économique
la nette qui voit un retour partiel sur
le mode de production capitaliste et un
renforcement du contrôle de l'état sur
la grande industrie lénine écrit
l'alliance entre la classe ouvrière et
la paysannerie doit être instaurée pour
de bon et pour longtemps
c'est dans les débats et les conflits de
cette époque là que lurs véritable celle
que l'on connaîtra par la suite
réellement émergent beaucoup plus que de
la révolution d'octobre 17 alors dans
cette période tout à fait essentiel des
années 20 on a à la fois je dirais les
grands acteurs historiques évidemment
lénine évidemment trotsky on commence à
voir émerger staline mais staline et
certainement pas en 1920 21 22
un des dirigeants de premier plan la
personne je dirais qu'ils émergent le
plus c'est quelqu'un de jeune que lénine
et la femme de lénine considère un peu
comme leur fils adoptif
c'est nicolas boukharine fait les
révolutionnaires ne se rendent pas
compte que le problème n'est pas de
faire la révolution c'est finalement
historiquement assez facile de faire une
révolution
les ennuis commencent le lendemain c'est
le jour d'après qu'on est confronté au
réel problème et boukari n'est confronté
au problème de la gestion du pouvoir
alors avec la guerre civile
bon les la situation extraordinairement
dramatique qui celle de la ce qu'on
appelle à l'époque la russie bolchévique
va évoluer et il va devenir un des
principaux partisans d'un système que
l'on pourrait bon avec un petit peu de
facilité qualifié d'économie mixte c'est
le système de l'aneth où la propriété
d'état reste dominante dans la grande
industrie mais il y a une propriété
privée
en ce qui concerne l'agriculture et
l'artisanat où il n'y a un appui assez
fort je dirai au développement de la
paysannerie et où existent des marchés
mais ce qui est très intéressant dans la
russie soviétique de l'anep c'est que
les transactions courantes se font sur
des marchés
à côté de cette option buhari nien il y
avait l'option défendue par trotsky qui
considérait qu'on ne pourrait pas
échapper à ce problème absolument
fondamental en russie comment réaliser
une accumulation du capital sans
ponctionner fortement la paysannerie et
donc qui prévoyait des produits
manufacturés très cher et des prix pour
les denrées agricoles extrêmement bas ce
qui évidemment risqué de mécontenter
durablement le paysan staline lui
n'avait pas d'options très clair sur la
question mais finalement il va procéder
à une véritable expropriation de la
paysannerie avec en lançant la
collectivisation à la fin de 1929 qui
ira bien au delà des propositions faites
par le groupe trotskiste en 1926 27
vladimir ilitch oulianov dit lénine
décède le 21 janvier 1924
déjà victime d'une attaque cérébrale en
mai 22 lénine avait abandonné toute
activité à la suite d'une nouvelle
attaque en mars 23
il avait entretemps rédiger un ensemble
de notes
improprement dénommé testament qui ne
seront rendus publics que plusieurs
décennies plus tard il si défi de
staline qu'il trouve trop brutale voire
dangereux et propose de le démettre du
poste de secrétaire général du parti
auquel celui-ci vient d'être récemment
nommé il y pointe les dangers de la
rivalité entre trotsky et staline et le
poids déjà excessive de la bureaucratie
après la mort de lénine trotsky
reprochent à la direction du parti ses
concessions capitaliste et dénonce la
dictature de l'appareil et la trahison
de la révolution d'octobre
développant sa théorie de la révolution
permanente mis en minorité
il doit quitter le commissariat du
peuple à la guerre
cependant que staline astor un véritable
culte de lénine ligne de gauche et ligne
de droite s'affrontent en 1925
quand d'une part zinoviev kamenev et
croupe sky à la veuve de lénine condamné
concession faite aux koulaks les paysans
riches et d'autre part boukharine et
staline affirme que les paysans doivent
s'enrichir pour produire au delà de
leurs besoins afin de nourrir la
population au courroux du 14e congrès du
parti bolchévik en décembre 1925 staline
se pose en médiateur entre boukharine et
zinovyev accusé par kamenev de gestion
dictatoriale
il esquive la critique et fait adopter
son propre rapport contrino fief il fait
nommer des proches au politburo kalinin
vorochilov molotov
ce dernier envoyé remettre de l'ordre à
leningrad ville dirigée par zinovyev en
obtiendra le limogeage et le
remplacement par un proche de staline
encore kirov
par le rapprochement de trotski zinovyev
et kamenev l'opposition signifie en 1926
mais elle est muselée face à staline qui
dispose de la police politique la
guépéou et de l'appareil du parti en
novembre 27 trotsky et zinovyev sont
exclus du parti
kameneff du comité central en décembre
lors du 15e congrès c'est autour d'une
centaine de membres de l'opposition
d'être exclu zino fief et kamenev plis
et font-ils autocritique humiliante
trotsky et ses proches sont exilés à
alma-ata au kazakhstan en janvier 1928
staline le fera assassiner à mexico 12
ans plus tard dans ses premières dix
années on peut dire 10 12 années du
régime bolchevique tel qu'il a été
instauré en octobre 1917 parmi les
éléments de qui vont marquer durablement
l'ensemble la période soviétique il y a
évidemment le fait qu' aucune opposition
n'est tolérée qu'il n'ya donc un
monopole du parti bolchévique
il y a également des structures qui ont
été mises en place dans la période de la
guerre civile notamment la police
politique la tcheka l'armée rouge qui
constitue une sorte d' épine dorsale du
système
d'ailleurs le rôle de l'armée est
extrêmement important pendant cette
première période surtout la peur de la
guerre si l'on peut vraiment parler d'un
modèle militaire qui structure le parti
lui-même le parti devient une
organisation beaucoup plus discipliné
qui s'est forgé dans le combat
dans la guerre civile dans le communisme
de guerre dans parmi les petits
fonctionnaires euros locaux presque tous
sont des anciens combattants de l'armée
rouge donc le passage par cette
expérience très forte et souvent
traumatisante de la grande guerre pull
us de la guerre civile a mené à la fois
une très forte brutalisation de la vie
politique mais aussi un certain style de
commandement qui va très durablement
influencé
on peut dire toute la période
stalinienne et ce n'est pas un hasard si
les dirigeants et staline en premier
lieu sont toujours vêtue d'une vareuse
militaire avec des bottes militaires au
moins dans cette période des années 30
lors du 15e congrès du parti bolchévik
en 1927
joseph staline ayant éliminé
l'opposition de gauche s'attaque à bout
karine herry kof qui critiquent
l'industrialisation inconsidérés alors
que les paysans ne livrent à l'état que
la moitié des céréales prévues
staline se détournent de la nef et
reprend de manière caricaturale les
thèses de la ligne de gauche considérant
que les paysans riches les koulaks sont
des saboteurs il ordonne une politique
de réquisition des récoltes son
hostilité envers les capitalistes ruraux
l'amène a créé en 1928 des forteresses
du socialisme à la campagne
exploitations collectives ferme d'état
station de matériel agricole que l'on
appelle kolkhoze sauf cause et mts
la paysannerie devra payer un tribut
élevé pour les besoins de
l'industrialisation mot karine est
horrifié par cette politique qui
conduira à la terreur et à la famine
oh
ils sont mon père est mon donc sa
première arrivée là bas
la bataille avant comment s'est
construit sa maison et aux îles nous
sommes tous en sibérie après comme il
faisait partie des moyens
c'était pas des koulaks c'était des
petits paysans c'était des gens très
riches et seulement deux chevaux il ya
deux vaches et c'est tout il y en à
l'appli est riche aussi habite à la
burqa village
le félin des moineaux il commence à la
collectivisation la colle cross il pas
son papa ou les aléas koleos parce que
échappe que chaque famille en aléa sont
mises en évidence en tout ils pas voler
le coffre ils se tout le monde ne
voulait pas rentrer dans le dans le
cosmos départ 10e commencer la mission
des casques bleus donc ils les ont
obligées de force pour ce procès voilà
ils ont forcé rossel ont confisqué donc
les terres entre qu'il y avait du
personnel donc les coûts lac en fête et
les gens pourraient rentrer à caen il ya
comme pointé la crosse tôt il y en a là
les riches tout se ressemble à l'état
voilà donc ils ont ils ont été
emprisonnés envoyée
en déportation et tous les biens ont été
confisqués tout compte fait la maison
tout autour les riches voilà et appeler
envoyer envoyé delà de leur camp les
mains la question de la continuité entre
léninisme et stalinisme et une question
absolument central dans
l'historiographie je ne pense qu'on ne
peut pas y répondre manière tout à fait
clair et net dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
beaucoup d'éléments du stalinisme
étaient présents dans le léninisme en
particulier ce refus de toute
alternative démocratique et pluraliste
ça c'est évident mais c'est vrai que
dans les années 20 il y avait au sein du
parti
plusieurs concours ans avec un certain
nombre d'alternatives et des choix
possibles des choix économiques des
choix politiques qui vont disparaître
lors avec l'arrivée de staline au
pouvoir qui ferme un certain nombre de
choix boukharine illustre bien à la fois
les je dirais les éléments positifs de
cette époque mais aussi ces tensions et
ses contradictions
et quand on regarde aujourd'hui les
éléments chiffrés dont on dispose
je ne suis toujours pas convaincu en
tant qu'économiste de ce que la
collectivisation était nécessaire et je
pense que là la vitesse de
l'industrialisation du développement de
la russie était en fait plus importante
dans les années 20 qui ne l'a été dans
les années 30
et c'est pour ça que j'ai le sentiment
que boukharine est un personnage qui à
l'époque est très moderne
il va mal finir
il sera chassé du pouvoir par staline
condamné dans un procès qui est un
procès-spectacle exécuté
boukharine tomski ryjkov sont écartés en
avril 29 une vaste purge est organisée
dans le parti qui va toucher plus de 10%
de ses membres la production agricole
s'effondre les prix flambent en mai 29
le congrès des soviets met en oeuvre le
premier plan quinquennal 20 % des
exploitations agricoles devront
s'intégrer dans les exploitations
collectives la collectivisation et
massive persuadé que la paysannerie est
majoritairement favorable kolkhoze
staline impose un plan irréalistes de
croissance industrielle et de
collectivisation c'est le grand tournant
au fond les années 30 c'est une certaine
manière une continuation sur d'autres
fronts de la guerre civile mais cette
fois ci contre l'ennemi intérieur qui va
donc mobiliser maintenant l'énergie du
parti dans ce grand tournant de la fin
des années 20